everybody what is going on welcome to
the 15th practical flash tutorial video
in this video we're going to be working
on our registration form so there's
multiple ways to actually generate the
HTML or at least send HTML to the
browser of the user the two main ways
that we can do that or either via flash
we can have actually flask push the HTML
to your or at least push code that will
render as HTML to your users browser or
we can actually code the HTML ourselves
now I prefer to actually write the HTML
myself and pass variables via flask to
that HTML but you might actually like
the idea of doing everything or mostly
everything via your flask you know your
Python files basically so that's just
going to be up to user preference now I
will just say that obviously there's far
more documentation if you're willing to
write the HTML yourself so you can find
how other people are doing all kinds of
fancy things whereas if you use pythons
you know or flash version you're gonna
have a little bit harder time to make it
look pretty let's say or incorporating
like Java Script that kind of stuff to
actually make your I don't know your
stuff look better but it's possible
either way so just keep that in mind
so anyway it'll come down to preference
so I figured why not show both I tried
both as well I just still happen to like
the HTML version but anyway let's go
ahead and get started so right now our
register page is pretty darn simple we
just have whoops not that page this page
uh so let's go sign up whoops that's not
what I want I want to go here dashboard
then sign up ok so right now this is our
register page not the best so what we
want to do is actually create the form
now we're going to create the form all
in flask and to do that we're going to
need a few things a few extra things so
first we want to get WT forms or what
the F ORMs that's what I see whenever I
see it anyway
first we're going to do pip install
flask - WTF
our ms I think that'll work otherwise we
might have to do sudo apt-get yeah it's
looking like it's not going to find it
um feel free if you know the correct pip
install feel free to post it below but
otherwise I guess we'll just do sudo
apt-get so sudo apt-get install last WTF
ah you're killing me you're killing me
ah
let's try hold on let's try the capital
like Debu forms like that and then so
we're okay fine fine fine let us so if
you can't find whatever you're looking
for Oh
skits flask WT forms like this we'll
just come over here and let's see WT
forms so flask - WTF let's try that one
let's do pip install flask - WTF
possibly there we go so pip install
flask - WTF sorry but the actual module
is going to be WTF forms uh so now what
we want to do is we're not going to need
it yet but let's just go ahead and do
actually I'll leave this I'll leave that
one out for now I was going to do the
the other package for the passwords but
we'll leave that out for now so now that
we have WTF forms the next thing that we
want to go ahead and do is let's go up
well I just will leave that out for now
first let's just create our registration
form so I'm going to move this aside and
here we have register page and that's
fine what we actually want to do is do
the following and let me actually go
let's just open up python real quick
import WT forms okay so yeah that's why
I was confused the actual module is
called WTF ORM s but for whatever reason
you you installed WTF there might be
more or W now cuz it WTF anyway whatever
move along so now let's we're gonna
define a class in this class
ass so do class registration form and
then we're going to pass the variable
form through it so here we were
basically let me get out of this D
control D to get out of it by the way
we'll go up to the very very top of our
page here and from WTF or MS import form
so let me just check that real quick
actually from WT forms import form okay
so that is the right syntax uh so we
want to do that so we can use form and
our registration form is going to
inherit from form so basically what
that's going to allow us to do is create
forms within Python and then the actual
the the result is going to be a form and
then we can actually put logic with that
form and do everything within our Python
script rather than having to do the
Jinja templating logic but again either
one works I actually tend to prefer
Jinja but England so first of all we're
going to name some fields so the first
field that we're going to have is just a
user name field so user name is going to
equal a text field like that and then
we've got user name and that's what's
going to be basically the valor the the
label to that and then here you're going
to at you can put in these parameters
called validators and what you can do is
do like something like validators length
and we're going to say the length has
some requirements so the minimum length
we're going to say is 4 and the maximum
length is 20 and so this is one reason
why you might want to use the WT forums
because you're able to actually put
logic like this in there and it's really
quick and easy as opposed to you know
having the post come in and then a
Python you maybe have some quick logic
that checks the length and stuff like
that for you so to save yourself from
having to add that extra logic you might
want to use these
anytime you want to have like length
logic for example so let's see did it
clear that yeah so that's done okay so
that's our username so we're allowing
users to have as little as four
characters in their name but a maximum
of twenty then we're going to have an
email field and again it's going to be a
basically the same field kind of so copy
this paste and this one is going to be
called email address and the minimum
length of an email we're going to say is
six I mean you can't you have even six
is basically impossible but whatever and
then max is going to be 50 okay so
that's an email and now we're going to
have a fancy one and that's password
password is going to equal password
field and what we're going to say is
we're gonna say password like this and
then comma and then we're going to have
a list here and then we're gonna say
validators dot required and then
basically this is going to mean that
this is going to be absolutely um
required that we have the following so
then the next thing is going to be
validators validators dot capital equal
capital t oh it needs to be equal to
confirm whichever one is confirmed and
then if not the error that is going to
be said is passwords must match okay so
we don't actually have this um confront
you know so it's got to be equal to
confirm we don't actually have confirm
yet so we're going to confirm so what
are we doing here this is the typical
you know what username do you want
what's the password to that username and
then confirm that password because what
if the users like typos their password
well they can't even see it first of all
but even if they can see it people would
probably typos from time to time and
then they would find out later
that they actually don't know what their
password is so that's why you have you
know two two passwords every now and
then you still see people only like half
like one password but it's a bad idea
so anyways confirm equals password field
again and then in here we're just going
to have the label be repeat password
password like that okay and then finally
we're going to have the requirement to
accepted Terms of Service so we're going
to say except underscore TOS and this is
going to be what's called a boolean
field so this will be like a checkbox
basically and in the boolean field we
can put some some text data so our text
that we want to say is just I accept D
and this will be um Terms of Service and
the privacy notice and then we'll just
normally put it updated in here so we
would say something like up last updated
last updated and 2015 actually you
probably need to give the full date so I
can say Jan 15 2015
and then obviously normally that would
be some form of like this here would be
like Terms of Service for example you
would say H ref equals and then we would
say TOS like that and then okay here
then you do the same thing for the
privacy notice so again you would have
some tags here a href equals a privacy
come on over close off the a tag there
last updated Jan 2015 that and let's see
and pull this up okay
and then so that is your boolean field
which begins with the I accept the Terms
of Service
all that and then you've got one more
thing that we add it's going to be all
the way at the end at the end you have
your quote comma and then again we want
to have this validators dot required
required and what that is is that's
basically this right here is required so
it's required this boom field right here
is filled and same thing here this
password is necessary right you have to
have a password in order to to make an
account okay so now that should be it
let me make this text a little smaller
it's hard for me to see everything
whenever we have that giant text but
it's easier for you to see if the text
is giant so let me just look at the
formula quick make sure we closed
everything off good good good good
there just close this one off as well
and then the accept Terms of Service
validators require let's check that one
as well okay yeah this one looks good so
that's our form and then now what we're
ready to do is incorporate this form
into our actual register page because
right now my register page doesn't do
anything but connect to our database in
return okay so now we're ready to
actually build the register page and
what we're going to do is we'll build
that and since we already have our
database we already have our connection
we'll actually probably finish the
registration page and actually have a
working registration in the next
tutorial so stay tuned for that if you
have any questions or comments on this
video please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support of
the subscriptions and it's still next
time